um right you've hopefully made the
heading already we are in this topic of
geometrical applications of differential
calculus getting better at say that time
twice not which is all about using
derivatives using this process of
differentiation to understand as the
name suggests the geometry of a curve
what's the shape look like what can we
know about where this thing's goes up
and down and and all that kind of thing
based on what we know of the derivatives
okay we started with the first
derivative that tells you of course the
gradient function right so that means
increasing decreasing or of course
stationary right and you can use that
first derivative all on its own in fact
it's the is the safest guaranteed way to
work out what kind of a stationary point
do you have we know there are broadly
speaking if three kinds of stationary
points what are they one two three what
kinds of things are we going to expect
okay we can add turning points of which
there are two kinds what kinds of Toni
points are there there's a maximum a
turning point and there's a minimum
turning point okay good so we know what
those are and then sorry actually before
we get to the third one how do I know
it's going to be either one of these
like what is the thing that tells me
it's a maximum it's a maximum it's going
to increase then you go stationary name
decreases so I'm looking for this
particular change in sign of course if
it's a minimum it's the opposite
it goes from decreasing to stationary to
increasing so we know what these
patterns look like what was the last one
the horizontal point of inflection so
this is where at a particular spot you
know the derivative is zero but on
either side it's got the same sign right
so it's like increasing increasing and
then stationary in the middle or
decreasing decreasing and stationary in
the middle so that's why it's not a
maximum it's not a minimum it's just
this weird kind of object in here okay
so roughly speaking you know what these
things look like okay
but the first derivative can be quite a
cumbersome and slow way to do it is
because you have to test here and here
and here you're going to know what's
going on you can got a constructive
table and that kind of thing so when we
introduce the second derivative we
learned that the second area doesn't
tell you about gradient it tells you at
this other feature that we saw that was
important start to the sea-cook cavity
right so being that the second
derivative tells you about concavity
that also corresponds to these three
kinds of features sort of if we get a
max turning point which direction is the
concavity of the curve which way is it
facing it's facing down okay remember I
always like to picture a cup like you're
holding a cup up right or you're holding
it down okay so this is concave down
which would mean that the second
derivative is what what do we know about
it it'll be less than 0 it would be
negative right so negative means down
concave down means maximum likewise if
you're concave up you have a minimum now
when it comes to the horizontal point of
inflection what do you think that
concavity would be at that point hmm so
we have to be really careful about this
we're going to explore this is such a
tricky nuanced thing we're not just
going to explore it this lesson we're
going to explore it we'll explore it
later today often most frequently you
will find that at that spot there here
there is no concavity it's not concave
up concave down remember where did my
part of that metal ruler go you don't
see we're in the middle limit it's
disappeared it was really useful this is
I don't want to snap this thing notice
it yeah
no seriously is it once it is it like in
nevermind oh I won't do it very much
this has already been broken okay so you
guys are witnesses this starts it this
ruler starts at 20 okay so not me we
know that concavity right is is this the
idea with what it's like I can hear it
sort of cracking I'm not gonna do it
okay is this idea of a flexing up or
flexing down okay
well if you have a straight line that is
exactly straight is it facing uppers are
facing down the answer is it's it's
neither okay there's a really easy way
to
further think about a straight line like
say that okay figure out a straight line
now we can get to the second derivative
just through our rules of
differentiation what's the first
derivative it's just going to be two
which indicates of course it's positive
its increasing just like you would
expect to X to do but when you
differentiate a second time to get to
that second derivative you're
differentiating a constant so what
happens to it so it's neither concave up
or concave down straight lines don't
have a concavity just like you've had a
lens and it was just a well if it was
just a window like a piece of glass it
doesn't lens the line it just goes
straight through no change okay so we
can use the second derivative to help us
work out what these things are and it is
often not always I'll get to that later
but it is often far more efficient so
here is our example function let's just
map out how we actually use the second
derivative and not just find an ATAR but
actually lay out the work and to show
why our answer is what it is if we start
with this guy we're gonna do a stock
standard thing find the stationary
points determine their nature so if I
want to find them what's my first step
okay
let's differentiate so this isn't easy
enough function you guys can do the
legwork for me no chain rule no product
rule required
what's the derivative 4x cubed minus 12x
squared cool so I found my derivative
what do I do with this thing why did I
find them after all I can go straight to
the secondary if I want I'm kind of in a
differentiating mood at the moment I
might as well since I've got it all
together and then I'll come back to this
first through I'm gonna need it
to find these stationary points right so
just while we're at it let's find this
second derivative if I differentiate
again because hipper weird symmetry of
this function your first term is going
to be 12x squared takeaway cool okay
we'll put that secondary second
derivative in our back pocket the second
derivative doesn't help you find
stationary points it really helps you
work out what kind of stationary points
they are so therefore I have to return
to this guy what will I do that okay I
want to find when it's equal to zero I'm
going to
say stationary points exist when okay
this these four words here that's that
tiny bit of connective tissue to explain
like I know why I'm doing this it's not
just because I'm following steps of an
algorithm like someone told me some
textbook example said I was supposed to
let it equal to zero I know why I'm
doing it okay I in other words 4x cubed
minus 12x squared equals zero tell me
what to do
factorize okay before I factorize
there's like something even easier I
could do probably divide everything you
by four okay now I'll factorize so what
would you like me to take out I can take
out x squared that's how many X is a
comment so that leaves me with X minus
three it's early in the morning I did it
okay good so at this one I factorize far
enough I found where my stationary
points will be X will be equal to zero
three fantastic okay